MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you all for joining
us for another Guest Chefs
at Google Los Angeles.
Today I'm very happy
to have Chef Sven
Mede from Santa Monica's
Casa del Mar hotel.
Sven has worked all
over the country.
He's worked with some
greatts, like the late great
Charlie Trotter, Bradley
Ogden, as well as Michael Mina.
He was named Rising Star Chef by
the the Star Chef's foundation.
Originally hailing from Germany,
now living in a Marina del Ray.
And he's here to make a
delicious seared shrimp
and vegetable salad for us.
So thank you guys.
SVEN MEDE: Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
Just to take all
the confusions away,
I'm the chef for Casa del Mar.
On your own little vouchers
there on the recipes,
it says By the Blue Sea.
Just to take this
right out there.
By the Blue Sea, it's
a group of restaurants.
I'm also in charge of the
restaurants at Shutters
On the Beach.
Some of you guys are familiar
with Casa del Mar and Shutters
On the Beach.
You guys been
there, some of you?
So at Shutters On the Beach, we
have a few restaurants-- Casa
del Mar, obviously
Catch and Lobby,
and we're in the progress of
building a new restaurant there
which will be a terrazza,
which will open in May.
So we're very
excited about that.
But today we're
talking about Catch,
and some great seafood
and some great vegetables.
And obviously with
the location here,
farmers markets
all over the place,
every day of the
week and the ocean.
And so that's what
we're trying to focus
on today, some light seafood.
And you guys, please questions,
keep going questions,
come up to look at it.
I will do a lot
of stuff up here,
so please walk up there if you
want to see something up close.
And keep asking questions.
OK so today we are
doing a shaved vegetable
salad and some seared shrimp.
So it sounds pretty simple.
It's really simple.
There's a couple steps to it.
First of all, we will start with
making a little vinaigrette.
So the great thing about
this recipe I picked today,
you can change these things out.
So right now it's citrus season.
I picked some tangelos.
Anybody knows what a tangelo is?
It's a mixture of two citrus.
Anybody knows?
Tangelo.
No?
So it's a tangerine
and a grapefruit.
So you get the sweetness
from the tangerine,
but you also get the
acid from the grapefruit.
OK, so we're using
that, and then we
got these great Meyer lemons.
Meyer lemons-- they're
a little bit sweeter,
they have a little bit more
flavor than the regular lemon,
just being just sour.
There's a little bit something
else to it, just lemon flavor.
So using these two,
and then we just need
a little bit olive oil for that.
So we starting with
citrus right here.
So I just-- you guys
should come up here,
and you can see actually
what's going on.
You guys want to come around,
a couple left, a couple right.
So I feel like I'm in the
classroom otherwise here, not
in a kitchen.
It's much more fun.
So citrus right here.
I just press some
of that juice here.
If you really like
the citrus, you
can also use the inside of them.
I'll get a little bit
more tangelo juice.
OK, and then the Meyer lemon.
What I do normally, I
just roll the citrus,
as it loosens up inside
the flesh a little bit,
and you get more juice
out of your citrus.
You see the color is also
a little bit different.
It's a bit more yellow
actually than a regular lemon.
All right.
We get some more of that.
OK.
So we have the acid now.
So now what we need
now it's our olive oil.
So what we do normally, we
just always add the olive oil
slowly into the citrus.
If you do a champagne
vinaigrette, same thing,
you take your oil,
and you slowly
add it into your vinegar.
New bottle?
Here it comes.
So very important
seasoning, always everything
gets seasoned.
And next step is everything
needs to be tasted.
So a little salt and pepper.
And then we get some
tastings spoons here.
You want a great
balance in that.
You want a little
bit of acid-- you
want a little bit
of the sweetness.
AUDIENCE: You moved over
this way and that way.
SVEN MEDE: Oh, we screwed
up the camera system?
Sorry.
And you want a little bit of
the richness of the olive oil.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SVEN MEDE: OK.
There we go.
A touch more.
So we're good on that.
That's our first step.
That was pretty simple.
Simple vinaigrette.
And you can exchange
with anything you like.
If you just want to
use pomegranate juice,
if it's like winter season,
you do the same thing.
Use some fresh
pomegranate juice,
you add some olive oil,
little salt and pepper.
Very simple.
Basic ratio is normally
like one to one,
if you use fresh juices
and some olive oil.
OK that's the first thing.
The next thing what we want
to do, we do a simple pickle.
What I will use for that,
we use these Fresno peppers.
So you can do anything you want.
The basic recipe is champagne
vinegar, sugar, and water.
So what we do
normally, we just use
equal parts of sugar and water.
You will bring
that up to a boil.
OK, let's see if
this thing works.
It does.
OK, and then after
this comes up boil,
I'm adding the same
amount I have in here.
I add the same amount
of vinegar to it.
That's your basic
pickling liquid.
You can use that
to pickle radishes,
peppers, onions, cauliflower,
anything you want to do.
It's always the same thing.
You have a recipe on
your little cards there.
It's very simple.
You make your liquid,
you put your vegetables,
you slice them thin.
You add them in to it,
just bring up to a boil,
let it cool down in the liquid.
If we have this going here,
it will take a second.
And you can use all
kinds of vegetables.
You can hold them in that liquid
for four weeks pretty much.
Just like you would
buy your pickles,
you can hold them in
the fridge, same thing
with your homemade pickles.
It will hold for long time
because of the vinegar inside.
But this comes up to a
boil, we'll just hold on.
I will start getting
these peppers cut.
So the peppers here, I'm
starting from the end here,
and just cut the
little end off here.
And then we just want to
slice them on the mandoline.
Kitchen tools.
Favorite kitchen
tools-- mandoline
is a great kitchen tool.
You can buy these fancy,
metal, gigantic things
for hundreds of dollars.
These are my favorite ones.
They're great, adjustable.
You can run them
through a dishwasher.
They're not as expensive
and they work perfectly.
They stay nice and sharp also.
They come in a smaller
size, and they also
come in this larger size.
It's a great kitchen utensil.
But they're sharp,
so be careful.
Don't cut yourself on this.
So this comes up to boil.
When this comes up, I just
add the vinegar to it.
Do a little stir around, here.
Let's make that's all
the sugar resolves.
OK.
So these peppers make sure
you hold, what I do here,
if you see that I hold onto
the bowl and the mandoline
at the same time so
it doesn't slide.
And just slowly go
back and forward.
And watch your fingers on that.
Same here.
If you get more to the end, the
slices get a little bit larger
and you have a little
bit more seeds.
What you want to do then,
is just pick the seeds out,
because the seeds already spicy,
don't have as much flavor.
It just adds extra spice to
it you don't really need.
Because you want the flavor
of the peppers, really.
That's what it looks like, you
have nice little slices here.
You see those?
OK, we don't need all these.
There you go.
So see this liquid
is coming up to boil,
what I do now, I just
at these peppers to it.
And since I have a lot of
liquid, it boils right away.
That's it, and I
just turn it off.
If it turns off.
It does.
Perfect.
Any questions at this point?
AUDIENCE: What kind of
ratio-- how many vegetables
do you want to put in?
SVEN MEDE: You just need enough
liquid to cover the vegetables.
I probably could add another
10 peppers here, probably,
cause we have a lot of liquid.
But you can reuse that liquid.
It actually picks up more flavor
if you use it the next time.
So if you finish eating
all your peppers,
you can take that liquid,
bring it up to a boil
again, and just slice
fresh peppers into it
and do it again.
Actually the flavor gets better
every time you're using it.
So we just reserve this here.
All right, I'll
put them over here.
OK, let's start working on
all our vegetables here.
So what I have here, about
to shave vegetable salad.
I picked a bunch of random stuff
from the market-- baby carrots,
radishes.
Anybody know what that is?
AUDIENCE: Daikon, I think.
SVEN MEDE: Daikon, very good.
They're used a lot
in Asian cooking.
I like it because
you can eat it raw,
it's not as spicy as a reddish.
It has a great texture,
especially in salads.
Cucumber, red
onions, we're using
all of these in our salad.
Give us a little space here.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: Do you go to the
local farmer's markets?
SVEN MEDE: Yeah,
mostly on Wednesdays,
cause it's the largest one
in downtown Santa Monica.
AUDIENCE: Is that the best one?
SVEN MEDE: I don't know
if it's the best one,
but I think it's
the largest one.
It has the biggest selection,
I think, of product.
And it's all
together on that day
so I don't have to go to smaller
markets throughout the week,
actually.
Everybody's there, all
the larger vendors,
smaller vendors.
It's the best selection
I would think.
Let's start with
our vegetable here.
using these cucumbers.
So we just cut the ends off.
You can change it up, any
vegetables you want to shave.
You can use fennel,
if you like fennel.
You don't like daikon,
use fennel instead.
As long as you slice
them very thin,
you can use all kinds
of different vegetables.
You even could use squash
or butternut squash,
or something like that.
It all works.
What I do here, just
peel the outside.
Just want to get
the skin off here.
The skin is a little bit bitter,
so you don't want to us that.
And again, there's
different cucumbers
at the farmers markets.
Right now, this one is
the best tasting one.
So what I do then, after
I'm done peeling the skin,
I just go over my bowl here.
I just keep peeling
these ribbons.
So we end up with these.
See that?
Nice thin ribbons?
And it's same thing I
would use the mandoline.
It's just easier
with the peeler,
actually less dangerous.
So we just keep going here.
Just keep turning.
You don't wanna use the seeds.
You just keep
turning the cucumber.
Just keep peeling
them down, until we
get enough for a salad.
I think that's a good amount.
Let's put this aside.
Next vegetable,
let's use the daikon.
Same thing with the daikon.
I cut a nice big chunk of it.
Again, start
peeling the outside,
just get rid of the skin.
And then, same-- let's get
this nicely cleaned up here.
OK, same thing.
So now we have this peeled side.
I go over my bowl
here, and just keep
peeling, again, these
nice beautiful ribbons.
You just have to keep turning.
The daikon's pretty wide and
your peeler's not as wide.
You just have to keep
turning it to make
sure you get the
same size of ribbons.
OK that's a good amount,
about the same amount
as the cucumber.
Next up, let's do baby carrots.
I have two different carrots
here, yellow and red.
You can use large
carrots if you like.
Like I said, you can use fennel.
You can even use cauliflower
or something like that,
there's nice different
colors of cauliflower
at the farmer's
market right now.
It also works.
The same process, I start
peeling the outside.
Go over here, and just
keep peeling it down.
That's good.
Let's do the red ones too.
All right.
Who goes to the farmer's
market of you guys?
Anybody goes on a regular basis?
What's your favorite
thing to buy there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SVEN MEDE: Yeah, I
mean that sounds great.
Right now the time for
greens is fantastic.
There's great greens there.
Citrus is really
popping right now.
So it's very exciting.
It's always something new,
that's the best thing about it.
OK, we have carrots.
See that's nice
different colors too,
because you get dark red
carrots, there's yellow,
there's white.
Just pick different colors up
and just peel them in there.
You can use it all
the way down, Just
keep peeling until there's
no carrot left pretty much.
I'll just stop right here,
because we don't have all day
and I know you guys
want to go back to work.
Or not.
All right, got carrots.
Next thing, let's
use some red onions.
Again you can use red
onions, you can use shallots,
you can use cipollini onions.
I just like to put some sort
of onion product into it.
It gives a nice little spice
to it, nice little kick.
Take the skin off here.
Here we go.
So now, here's the difference.
It doesn't work with
the peeler any more,
now we have to
use our mandoline.
I just cut the
end of it off so I
have a nice flat surface here.
Let's get this wiped
off a little bit.
So onion, right over here,
hold it together like this.
There we go.
We have these nice
beautiful thin little slices
of red onions.
Everybody always like, how
you do this with your knife?
How sharp is the knife you use?
There's no knife, I
don't use a knife at all.
Just a mandoline and a peeler.
It's all you need for that.
Let's do some radishes.
I like radishes because it
has a little spice to it.
There's lots of
different types, they
have yellow ones, red ones.
The English breakfast
radish is what that is.
This a medium spicy radish.
Works great for
salads like that.
Let's grab a nice one here.
I already washed
these vegetables,
so we don't have to
worry about that.
I actually did.
[LAUGHTER]
I prepared before
you guys came here,
and I actually washed them.
OK, so slice the end off again.
And then thin slices.
And you gotta make sure
you keep looking and that.
I can look away, but I wouldn't
recommend doing that at home.
There we go.
So you end up with
these nice slices here.
Nice and thing again.
You see, end of
the day, everything
has the same thickness.
So if you eat your salad,
you have different textures,
different flavors,
but everything
is the same thickness.
So the salad marinates
really well like that.
OK what are we missing?
We got this, we got
radishes, carrots, cucumbers.
Very good.
So all there.
So now just clean
some of it up here.
Done with this, and that.
So next, let's
talk about shrimp.
What I have here, is
called a blue prawn.
That's what it looks like.
So when it comes
to shrimp, there's
a lot of different types
of shrimp obviously around,
some good ones, and then
some not so good ones.
I prefer to buy shrimp
inside the shell, not peeled.
Because you have
more possibilities
in how you want to use them.
Same as with meat.
If you cook meat on the
bone, that more flavor to it.
A bone-in rib-eye
always has more flavor
then a boneless rib-eye.
Same comes to seafood.
If you cook a
whole fish, there's
more flavor to a whole fish
because you're cooking it
on the bone, than
a filet of fish.
Same goes with shrimp and
lobster and other crustaceans.
So cooking a shrimp inside the
shell, in some applications,
has much more flavor, you see.
Like with the live spot
prawns and things like that,
you just cut them half.
That's what they
do at a restaurant.
You just split
this whole shrimp,
put them on the grill,
salt and pepper, olive oil,
and you serve them in the
shell, because there's
a lot of flavor for that.
Now for our application
today, since we're just
doing a simple
salad, you don't want
to start peeling the
shrimp with your salad,
it's kind of getting messy.
So what we did here,
we just peeled them.
We cut them in half,
pretty much like this.
So we just get this
pan going here.
Catching up?
You ready to go?
Because these people
are hungry, OK?
So you better be ready.
So get this nice and hot.
Real simple, just a little bit
of olive oil, salt and pepper.
What I do normally, I just
season my meat or fish
in a separate bowl instead
of just putting too much oil
inside.
The balance is better if you
season your things in the pan,
season it in a separate pan, and
then put it in the frying pan
so you don't end up
with lots of excess oil.
Salt and pepper.
We really like using sea salt.
Much more flavor, it's a
little bit healthier too.
And it's a nice thing cause it
has a nice little texture to it
too.
Especially if you finish things,
finish meat, finish fish.
It has a nice
little crunch to it,
and it has much more
minerality and flavor than just
regular kosher salt.
And then pepper.
We always use pepper
mills at the restaurant,
because it's fresh ground
instead of just buying
pepper ground all ready.
It's nice to have a pepper mill.
What we do normally, we
toast the peppercorns.
What it does, it brings
a little bit more flavor
out of the spices.
A lot of spices, especially
in Asian cooking,
you always toast the
spices before using them.
Same we do with the peppercorns.
Just a little pan over heat,
toast the peppercorns, and then
put them into the pepper
mill, so it's much more
flavor out of the peppercorns.
OK we'll season that.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
question about the oil?
SVEN MEDE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you use olive oil.
I know that some people
use more neutral oils.
Is the olive oil flavor
going to stay with the shrimp
after it has cooked?
SVEN MEDE: It stays a
little bit in there.
And I think it fits the concept.
AUDIENCE: Repeat
the question, sorry.
SVEN MEDE: The question
was, why using olive oil?
I really like using
olive oil for things
like that, because it
goes with the salad.
If I just want to cook
something separately
but nothing to do this,
I may use grape seed oil.
If I need to fry
something very hot,
you use a peanut oil
or something like that.
For this application where I
don't use a very high heat,
I just want to have a little bit
carmalization on the outside,
and then adding it to
a salad and decide also
to have olive oil.
I think it fits better using
olive oil for that application.
This pan should be good.
So let's get these in here.
When it comes to
cooking shrimp, meat,
anything like that, the
worst thing that can happen
is that the pan is really
too hot or too cold.
You can hear it normally
on the sound of your pan.
If it starts to explode
and getting really, really
loud when you put
this meat in the pan,
it means the pan is too hot.
If nothing happens,
you can't hear
anything, that means the pan
is probably too low in heat.
You want to have a
little sound of it.
Let's turn this
down a little bit.
I started with a little
bit higher heat ,
you get to see on it.
And now I've turned
the heat down.
Let's see if I figure
out this stove.
I do.
Here we go.
If it smokes too much, then
you can add a touch more oil.
What it does, pretty much,
is cooling the pan down.
And don't be scared, you
can take the pan off.
I don't need heat right now.
Obviously the pan is hot so
I just take it to the side.
You see the shrimp curled up.
In this application,
it doesn't matter.
In some other
applications, sometimes
what they do with the shrimp,
they put skewers inside.
They make a little
wooden skewer.
With whole lobster, they
put the skewers inside,
and tails stay straight.
Only if you want to have a
perfect plate of something
like that.
This application
where we're just
doing the salad, the shrimp
like that is perfectly fine.
Let me flip these over again.
Next thing you want
to keep an eye on,
there's nothing worse
than overcooked meat.
I know people are always
scared to undercook
it, don't wanna have it raw.
But I think it's much better
to just take one piece,
and cut in half and look
at it, and then check
if it's cooked or not cooked.
Instead of just cooking it and
you say, no another minute,
another minute, next thing
you know, it's just dry
and you can't go
back from this point.
So you always want to
just stop it and say,
hey is it done or not?
Just take one piece, cut
it in half, look at it.
If it's done, it's done.
If not, just put it back in the
pan for another minute or two.
So that's pretty much done,
let's turn the thing off.
Let's push them aside.
There we go.
Let's put our salad together.
First I have the
vegetables here,
let's get them all in here.
And now our dressing.
And the ratio is only
about a tablespoon
per serving of the
salad, as a basic recipe.
I used a teaspoon, so I
use a little bit more here.
There we go, that's good.
Again, we mix it
around a little bit.
And very importantly,
you want to taste it.
Just take a little piece here.
this needs a touch more salt.
Start putting it together.
Are you ready over there?
I'm going slow for you.
So salad right in the middle.
That's a nice,
fresh, summer dish.
With the citrus,
but like I said,
you can server this in winter.
Use butternut squash and
pomegranate vinaigrette
and now you have a
great winter salad too.
Let's do some of the
pickles on top here.
Great kitchen tool, by the way.
I don't know if I
said that already.
Every chef's new
favorite, I know
it didn't exist until 10 years
ago, but now everybody has one.
It's the tweezers.
You can do stirring,
you can take things our,
you use it for frying,
turning over your steaks.
I use it at home
for barbecue, it
did do them in small,
large, anything.
It's just a perfect
kitchen tool by the way.
Shrimp.
And then let's--
something nice and fresh,
let's add a little
cilantro leaves.
The reason you had nice cilantro
flowers at the farmer's market.
Unfortunately we couldn't
get them anymore.
But like I said, you can
exchange these things.
Cilantro flowers,
arugula flowers.
If you want a more
substantial salad,
you actually could add a little
bit arugula to your vegetables,
too, and make it more
like a composed salad too.
So we added some cilantro here.
Just to finish, can just put a
little more vinaigrette on top,
like that.
That's it, we have
a nice, fresh salad.
Now for anybody who
wants a little more
kick to it, because these
are more like sweet and sour.
There's a little spice
to it, but not a lot.
At the restaurant, what
I use sometimes too,
it's this pepper. it's
called an espelette.
It's a Spanish pepper.
It has a little bit more citrusy
notes and a little more flavor
to it than just regular
chili flakes, for example.
It just gives a
nice little kick.
If you like food a little
more spicy, nice little spicy
pepper on top, you can
finish a dish like that too.
That's it, very simple.
Was it difficult, easy?
Fairly easy, no?
Any questions, anything else?
No?
Who comes back now and
does the same again?
Anybody wants to do
this whole dish again?
No?
All right.
We have someplace ready
for you guys here.
Let's try it, and if any
more questions, let me know.
AUDIENCE: So roast
the peppercorns
before I put it in the mill?
SVEN MEDE: Uh-huh.
Just toast them.
AUDIENCE: You have to do
this just before you use it?
Or can you just do it once
and then keep it for months?
SVEN MEDE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You toast
and then you put away.
SVEN MEDE: Not months, but
I refill it once a week.
Normally we go through it.
But I mean you don't
have to fill your pepper
mill all the way.
You can just toast us a handful,
and put them inside the mill,
and it's enough for like
two weeks, or three weeks.
And then just don't fill
the pepper mill all the way.
But you get much more
flavor out of them.
AUDIENCE: Where'd
they get this shrimp?
SVEN MEDE: This shrimp, its
from Santa Monica Seafood.
There's a storage
here in Santa Monica.
This one is a frozen shrimp.
The thing with shrimp, it's
always like getting fresh.
In supermarkets it
says fresh shrimp,
but if you read the small print,
it says previously frozen.
So it's better to
buy some of this one.
It's a sustainable shrimp, and
it's frozen right on the boat.
It's been frozen the whole time,
it's not like frozen defrosted.
So it's really
consistent that way.
A lot of chefs going
that direction now.
It's very hard to get
really fresh shrimp which
was fresh from the catch.
You can get some of them, but
you only get it once a week,
or every second week.
So it really depends
on the weather.
So a lot of chefs
can't depend on that,
if you have a
restaurant where you
need to have consistent product.
That's a really good shrimp.
It's soft.
It has different applications.
You can fry it.
You can sear it or grill it,
it always stays kinda moist.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
the biggest challenge is
when working with seafood?
SVEN MEDE: I think first you
have to pick good product.
Like we just talked
about the shrimp.
Using the right
product, good product.
Just kind of handing it right.
Make sure we don't leave
it three days in the fridge
before you cook it.
You want to make
sure it stays fresh.
And just don't overcook it,
make sure you season it well.
That's pretty much as you get
in our restaurant catch too.
A lot of different
seafoods made raw.
Make sure all the
stuff stays fresh,
and keep focused on
the cooking techniques.
And make sure it's
not overcooking.
You don't want to server
overpowering things
with your seafood,
just more like this.
Because it highlights
the seafood.
If you could do a
really heavy risotto
with a delicate piece of
fish, what's the point?
You don't taste
the fish anymore.
AUDIENCE: Do you come
across unusual things
at the farmer's
market and think,
how am I going to use this?
SVEN MEDE: Yeah, sometimes.
There's some tropical fruits.
Something I have
no idea what it is.
I just take one
and just Google it.
And then find out about it,
and then just try it out,
if you like it or don't.
Yeah.
That's what's fun about
the farmer's market
here, because there
are these farmers that
have stuff you only see for
two weeks out of the year
or something like that.
Which is exciting.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
significant differences
between making one
serving and [INAUDIBLE]?
SVEN MEDE: It's the same
thing, because the preparation
are basically the same.
You just made a bigger batch.
Obviously you shave lot
of vegetables separate,
so you had a bowl
of shaved radishes,
and a bowl of shaved carrots,
and things like that.
Depends on many
people you just saw,
mix it all in one big salad.
Make a salad, and instead of
searing four pieces of shrimp,
you sear 20 pieces of shrimp.
AUDIENCE: If you're
you're entertaining,
how far ahead of time do
you preslice the vegetables?
And then I guess
you assemble it--
SVEN MEDE: These vegetables, you
can slice them the day before.
Some vegetables you
can keep it in water,
and some vegetables you just
put a moist paper towel on top,
so make sure they don't dry out.
The cucumber, the
radishes just stay nice
if you put it in a
little cold water.
The radishes normally I like to
just put a paper towel on top
so you don't lose the
spiciness of them.
But you can prep
that a day ahead.
You have the vinaigrette
done a day ahead.
The pickles, like I said, you
can make them two weeks ahead.
So you only have to
really mix it together
when you sear the shrimp.
AUDIENCE: What was that
last pepper called again?
The Spanish one?
SVEN MEDE: It's
called espelette.
if you guys want to try a
little bit here, just to see.
But also if you just
want to try a little bit.
You can see it's actually--
it has more notes to it
than just spice.
There's a little citrons, a lot
of different components to it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SVEN MEDE: Yeah.
I'm sure Whole Foods probably
has it or somebody like that.
Any questions, anything else?
Thank you everybody,
thanks for coming.
Hope to see you soon
at the restaurant.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.